well when I was born here there's about
80 people here there's five now but it's
all I've ever really known and it
doesn't seem that abnormal to me in the
90s the Park Service wanted to start
kind of like a living walking museum in
the town to capture the old coal mining
ambience of town that exists here that's
kind of lost in other towns the Park
Service bought a lot of the houses from
the local people and we could afford to
not have to sell the other family that
lives here is the dragon family
Melanie dragon is the mayor
her daughter Missy is a City
Councilwoman with me her husband
Missy's husband chad is a town recorder
and Missy's aunt is a Cindy is also a
city council woman
we're an open inviting community that
that tolerates people from all walks of
life
our state doesn't offer that protection
on a statewide level so we wanted to go
above and beyond that is anyone gay here
no nobody's get here in practical terms
it was symbolic I think what this town
needs is young people that care about
the environment and that care about
their communities and that's probably
true for most places but I think that's
especially true for Thurmond I think
that anyone with a little bit of
entrepreneurial aspirations and
compassion towards something that that
they love I think anyone would do
successful here
you